[Musique]
qui ne s'est pas déjà aventuré ne serait
ce que quelques minutes sur wikipédia
cette encyclopédie en ligne et à des
sites web les plus visités au monde
créée il ya plus de vingt ans wikipedia
découle du principe du wiki c'est à dire
un site web collaboratif au fil du temps
une armée de wikipédiens a contribué à
la production de 57 millions d'articles
rédigés en plus de 300 langues dont un
peu plus de 2 millions en français
nicolas en allant de la fiabilité de
wikipédia c'est ça qui nous intéresse en
gros aujourd'hui comment l'évaluer
comment la qualifier qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire là dessus c'est ce que
différentes point de vue sur la
fiabilité de wikipédia ya une
professeure et épistémologue américaine
amy brockmann qui étudie justement les
communautés en ligne steam a publié l'an
prochain un livre sur wikipédia qui dit
que le site peut être la source la plus
fiable du web mais dans les
circonstances mais particulière je
m'explique les articles les plus
populaires sur des sujets chauds des
sujets d'actualité des sujets qui font
couler beaucoup d'encre pour partie à la
coved ou même des personnalités
politiques bien qu'un nul mais ces
articles l'heure c'est comme une espèce
de révision des pertes massives sa part
là dessus selon la professeure brockman
wikipedia mais une fois qu'on écrit
quelque chose là dessus c'est des
milliers personnes en temps réel qui
peuvent le voir peut le modifier que peu
le mettre à jour et il ya une espèce de
consensus qui se crée quand il ya autant
de personnes qui contre ballet des
informations sur un site web comme ça
selon madame brockman c'est même plus
fiable qu'une révision par les pairs
d'une étude scientifiquement dans ces
circonstances spécifiques le mais des
articles qui sont moins consultés sur
des sujets plus ni chez le elle dit que
la fiabilité dans ces cas là et est
moins certaine mais le modèle de
wikipedia en soit il ya du bon là dedans
très certainement dans quelle mesure ça
peut être un modèle pour d'autres
plateformes numériques qui sont
vertement critiqué par les temps qui
courent je pense à facebook notamment
oui bon c'est sûr que le fondateur de
wikipedia en fait jimmy wales il ya une
couple d'années il ya 10 20 facebook
devrait s'inspirer de modèles de et
employés des bénévoles pour modérer sa
plate forme parce que wikipedia faut le
mentionner les occuper d'un spa des gens
qui sont payés pour faire cesser des
gens passionnés le qui sont constamment
sur le site à surveiller ce qui se passe
la femme avec facebook oui des
modérateurs humain mais si beaucoup à
l'ia pour modérer leur plateforme alors
que wikipedia c'est beaucoup plus axé
sur l'être humain donc je pense que s'il
ya une chose à retenir c'est que des
êtres humains peuvent faire une bonne
job d'ici peuvent engager plus d'êtres
humains ont modéré leurs plateformes
mais ça reste peut-être de contrôler un
peu mieux la propagation de
l'information sur facebook
dans l'univers de wikipédiens le
québécois miguel tremblay est un
pionnier ce physicien de formation
figurent parmi les 100 premiers
contributeurs francophones de cette
gigantesque encyclopédie en ligne à lui
seul il cumule dix mille contributions
ce qui le place parmi les utilisateurs
les plus actifs et sa participation à
clairement montée d'un cran avec la
pandémie
il ya travées bonjour bonjour bienvenue
décrypteurs vous êtes un contributeur
très actif ici au québec depuis
longtemps comment ça a commencé ça
commencé en 2003 mes amis qui m'avait
parlé d'un site web où on pouvait faire
des modifications et les enregistrer
directement alors c'est la première fois
que je rencontrais ce principe leur qui
s'appelle un wiki et donc j'avais été
époustouflés de voir qu'il existait un
site web qu'on pouvait modifier nous
mêmes et en temps réel les modifications
apparaissait donc c'est comme ça que ça
a commencé et puis la copie de 10,9 me
donner
regain parce que je trouvais qu'il y
avait très peu d'informations pas assez
et puis si j'ai décidé de prendre ce
sujet sur mon aile et puis la mémé
contribution augmenter quelle est la
valeur ajoutée trouvez-vous wikipédia
dans un contexte de pandémie au cours
des premières banques c'est que
wikipedia permet de faire une synthèse
les médias sont beaucoup ce qui se passe
en temps réel
ici et maintenant alors que si on veut
avoir un recul et avoir plus
d'informations sur plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois jusqu'à présent dans les
médias c'est pas leur mandat donc sur
wikipédia mais mon objectif était de
faire cette synthèse autres de mettre
les informations pour qu'un lecteur
intrigué dans le futur plus voir de
façon synthétique qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant la coved 19 part au québec
par exemple les
les pallie les couleurs de pallier par
région administrative caen s'était
instaurée donc à voir l'historique de
ces paliers là donc on a créé un table
où on voit chaque couleur avec chaque
date et on à l'évolution de ces paliers
là dans le temps ce qui n'existe pas à
ma connaissance ailleurs que sur
wikipédia alors ce qu'on a vu au québec
je sais pas si c'est la même chose
ailleurs mais la production sur la
pandémie a été assez soutenue l'an au
début oui de façon générale quand un
nouveau sujet qui émergent dans
l'actualité les contributions la
création d'articles sur wikipédia est à
l'avenant donc en ce moment on ne va
rien au micron qui a été découvert et
quelques jours donc les articles ont
déjà été écrits dans 28 langues sur
wikipédia et les contributions vont bon
train l'article sur le variant au micron
en anglais le lendemain de sa création
était consulté plus de 90 mille fois
donc
c'est vraiment un sujet d'intérêt il ya
beaucoup d'attrait et c'est vrai aussi
pour les contributeurs de wikipédia qui
se mettent à rassembler l'information à
un endroit dans un article comment on
peut rassurer les gens sur la validité
des informations qui sont véhiculées sur
wikipédia question les balises
existantes au fil du temps il ya
plusieurs méthodes mesures qui ont été
mises en place pour surveiller les
contributions premièrement il existe ce
qu'on appelle une liste de suivi c'est à
dire que les contributeurs vérifie ont
une liste d'articles ou auxquels ils
sont avisés lorsque des modifications
celui-là pandémique ovide 19 sur
wikipédia 233 aux utilisateurs inscrits
qui sont avisés lorsqu'une modification
d'une part donc les plus l'article et
vue plus il ya des gens qui regardent
toutes les modifications
d'autre part il ya des balises donc ce
qui quand c'est fait par un utilisateur
qui n'ont enregistré on a fait surtout
adresse ip donc toutes ces modifications
la sont révisés et puis il y avait moyen
de protéger une page si on voit que trop
de vandalisme ce qui arrive souvent dans
les coques personnalité par exemple
lucie laurier où éric duhaime ont été se
sont soumis à une semi protection c'est
à dire que les gens qui ne sont pas
inscrits ne peuvent pas les modifier et
ceux qui sont inscrits depuis moins de 5
jours et au moins 200 contributions ne
peuvent pas les modifier comme non plus
donc en faisant ça on élimine environ
98% des actes de vandalisme et de
fausses informations wikipedia
doubs est un excellent point de départ
pour faire d'autres recherches n'ont
pour en revenir à votre première
question comment on peut s'y fier
simplement en démarrant de cet endroit
là et en allant voir les sources qui
sont indiqués pour chacune des
informations donc c'était wikipedia est
peut-être pas recommandée mais débuter
leur pour commencer une recherche pour
une loi suite avoir des situations où
des sources est un excellent point de
départ est souvent il ya des gens qui
ont fait un travail de fond extrêmement
il ya beaucoup d'énergie qui a été
investi là qui n'est pas à refaire par
la suite évidemment comme tout outil est
comme d'autres entités sur le web il ya
sûrement des correctifs apportés c'est
pas la perfection absolue est-ce que des
points à améliorer dans wikipédia en ce
moment la représentativité est
certainement un point qui achoppe donc
la majorité des contributeurs mon profil
sadique ce sont des hommes blancs
universitaire en haut de 30 ans dont qui
s'intéressent à des sujets d'hommes
blancs universitaire en haut de trente
ans donc souvent il s'y est pas d'effort
qui est mis pour justement créer des
articles et qui concernent des cdd
personnalité de femme bien il le biais
persiste mais dans un contexte où les
gens savent pas vers qui se tourner vers
quoi se tourner on a discuté a vulgarisé
par exemple les études scientifiques
est-ce que wikipédia est un outil de
vulgarisation justement pour combattre
la désinformation c'est son objectif
donc le pdi par définition ça c'est fait
pour simplifier pour représenter de
façon
j'ai ce type d'information complexes
donc c'est dans son monde au premier on
l'espère que c'est comme ça il ya du
travail à faire commun dans n'importe
quel domaine mais c'est vraiment sa
visée merci beaucoup monsieur tremblay
merci à vous